commentant les sondages favorables à son
adversaire Jacques Chirac il a aussi
ironisé sur les ralliments de certaines
personnalités de gauche h sont les
hommes les hommes son les hommes la
gauche caviar découvre la tête de veau
c'est très bon la tête de veau c'est
très très bon il faut pas en abuser à la
longue c'est indigeste expliquant son
rôle dans l'entreprise informatique GSI
il a fustigé les attaques à son encontre
sur ce dossier bien garde cette campagne
électorale est en train de prendre un
très mauvais tour moi j'ai dit ce que
j'avais à dire et j'en ai dit plus que
n'importe quel autre jusqu'à ce
jour et c'est parce que je suis un homme
libre qu'on s'en prend à moi